thank you for joining us America this is
the Dave Ramsey show Paul starts off
this segment from Seattle hey Paul how
are you I'm doing well Dave thanks for
taking my call and God bless you for
everything that you do you're a great
guy thank you sir
not going to help you today I'll cut to
the chase a little over ten years ago I
had a break up in a relationship and I
walked away I had no place to stay
my mom reached out and she bought a
mobile home in a park for $8,500 I
agreed with her I said oh I will pay you
$10,000 hundred dollars a month I'm
trying to get on my feet I was hurt at
work so that kind of slowed down things
so payments were intermittent at times I
had a legal issue I got a DUI about
three months ago and she got mad she
sold the place and my equity at that
point was seventy five hundred dollars
so out twenty-five hundred more she
turned around and sold the mobile home
for sixteen thousand I'm wondering do I
have a claim on my $7,500 worth the
equity that's my big question is any of
this in I hiding and I have all my
receipts I paid the taxes I paid the
space rent is the deal in writing the
$10,000 $400 a month
yes I have that okay in what form is it
a deed or a you know a handwritten thing
both by her and I and signed by both of
us okay well um what a horrible thing so
she sold it and doesn't want to give you
any money basically that's that's about
it she sold it for 16 plus she's got the
seven five on top of that so she's
walking away with 23 five and leaving me
hanging I guess mm-hmm okay well I mean
and obviously you've talked to her about
it I mean what'd she say she doesn't
feel like she that the oh you all had
was a deal uh she brought up a point and
this is kind of off subject but she says
you know while you lived there for forty
seven dollars and fifty cents per month
out of the 7,500 what
did what she took the number divided it
by the months that I've lived there and
said you know where else can you live
for that Adele annulment that doesn't
matter
that doesn't matter what matters is is
that I deal with you to buy the thing
for ten thousand dollars I've paid
seventy five hundred of that I was late
on the payments and so you foreclosed
and sold it
basically yeah I was basically in her
name until it was paid off yeah I
understand which is a bad deal for
everyone involved obviously this whole
deal is a very bad deal so it sounds
like I mean I don't know I have no idea
I'm not an attorney I'm certainly not an
attorney in the state of Washington I
guess you could see one because it
sounds like the only way you're going to
get money from her is to sue her right
well who wants to sue their mom I know
but who wanted out who wants to read
about their son well sometimes the best
deals that you put down in your family
turn out to really be screwball yeah so
I mean you really have two choices one
is she's not she's taking the money oh
yeah she's got her 23 five including
what she sold it's gone it's gone and so
the only way you and she looked at you
and said you're not getting me this
money so the only way you're getting the
money sewer because you've tried to talk
her into it right um it's been a very
tenuous type of you know conversation
yeah so I mean you might try to talk her
into it some more but I you know the
only other option is to have a judge
force her to do it now will you win that
if you went before a judge I have no
idea I mean because then there's a house
both of you were both of you're stupid I
mean you have a hand-written bad
document and you set up this horrible
deal that you know now she has
foreclosed on now maybe the judge says
you didn't pay the bill so you got
foreclosed on because if the bank
forecloses on you and takes your house
and sells it they don't owe you any
money and if she foreclosed on you and
took the house she doesn't owe you any
money if that's the legal stance that
they take that the courts take that's
you won't get anything if on the other
is the word for when you use the word
foreclosure well it's a land con it's a
matter contract yeah it's a land
contract but you were in default on
because you didn't pay the payment and
so she confiscated it and sold it off
the land contract and so in most states
that would be a foreclosure type action
and that's what she's done effectively
for a business or a legal standpoint now
you know how's the judge going to look
at it I don't know I would say you're
both going to get dressed down if you
walk before a good judge he's probably
going to call both of you out so you got
really kind of two choices I guess
content three one is just forget it and
go that's it next next
you know I screwed up I got a DUI I
couldn't pay the bill she sold the thing
out from under me note to self don't do
big deals with mom you know and then
next right you can walk away the second
thing you could do is continue to try to
talk her into sharing some of it with
you or and then the third thing is if
she won't do that obviously you could go
to court those are your three options
right what what is your income situation
your financial situation today right now
I'm living in my car and I'm finding
work through temporary services and
stuff like that
but nobody in my family will touch me
you know I'm one of five kids and
everybody's hands off four of them live
in this earth three of the five live in
my area nobody's offered me a room or
anything like that so and the reason is
your continued substance abuse in the
duis right well it's because of that
yeah then that was my second one so
that's why they've they pull back
they're not going to support that
behaviors what they're saying I hear you
that's that I think I mean I'm not being
harsh but I mean I'm just trying to
understand why so what I would do I
guess if I'm in your shoes is one is I
would talk to her and say mom can you
you know I understand what's happened
it's my fault I brought this on myself
but I did pay $7,500 in over a period of
years and yes that was a good deal but
if there's such a thing as a good deal
on a trash hole of a trailer but that's
what I was living in right but I had a
good deal on a trash hole of a trailer
and thank you for that and and I'm not
you know this is my fault just own it
don't don't accuse her so can you share
some of that with me to at least let me
get up
man get off the street get out of my car
I have no one to blame but myself no if
you'll just take that approach with her
maybe that's persuasive to her and
she'll help you get set up at an
apartment or something and give you know
thousand bucks out of the 7500 or
something and then count it from there
and use this as your starting point to
go forward I'm not going to pursue mom
and Sewer if I'm into that if I'm in
your shoes I'm just not I because I
think you both did a bad dumb deal and I
you know you might or might not win I
don't know but you're going to lose many
splendored wealth loves them any
splendor things sometimes and you're
looking out for your kids yeah but
you're going to lose you're going to
lose the relationship obviously if you
win and so it's just I wouldn't even go
that way I'd rather walk away now you
know lose that I think damage done and
lastly I would tell you this there's a
lot of really good churches in the
Seattle area and I think you ought to
just swing in and sit down and talk to
one of the pastors there and catch
somebody and say hey I own this I
brought this on myself I'm trying to get
back up on my feet is there anything
that can be done that I can work I can
do around the church here anything I can
do to protect that you guys would
participate in helping me get out of my
car and I'm not asking you know for a
permanent handout and I'm not I'm just
asking for some mercy and some help and
most churches have benevolence programs
they usually involve work they usually
involve prayer they usually involve
church attendance all of which are going
to be good for you in this situation so
try to get you know plugged into some
network like that to help you get back
on your feet
check with some 12-step folks in the
area and see if you can get plugged in
there too and you'll find some people
that tell you the truth there that love
you and that will walk with you as you
turn this around and Paul you call me
any time as you're taking taking your
walk through this and if there's
something I can do to help you I will
I'd send you a I'm happy to send you a
book it seems kind of lame right now
you're living in your car but I'll do it
you know so you hold on and I'll have
Laura pick up and if there's a way we
can get it to you we will and we'll try
to serve you and help you any way we can
and you call me back if you need help as
you're on this journey you know turn and
turn in something like this around can
be done man you have really been through
it and you've been through
in 10 years so hey thanks for the call
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you can do this you know that
really is a message whether you've got
two hundred seventy thousand dollars in
student loan debt or 27 thousand well
you've got a fifty thousand dollar
income a five hundred thousand dollar
income